so we're going to move on to
probably one of my new favorite lines in
chess
the napoleon gambit i went down a rabbit
hole with this one
and honestly this line probably deserves
a chess openings explained video of its
own
um
i was going through and it looked like
the theory
there's actually like
not much theory here but i was doing
some engine analysis and playing some
lines against uh one of my co-workers
here
and there's quite a few only moves that
both sides need to know
so
we'll get our scotch here and they take
on d4 we're going to take on d4 with the
knight and after they take back with the
pawn
we're not going to take on d4 with the
queen
instead we're going to play bishop to c4
and this is known as the napoleon gambit
and
this opening gets its name from a game
between napoleon bonaparte versus one of
his generals back in 1818
now
uh in that game
black decided to go bishop c5 and this
is one of the first ideas of the
napoleon gambit
that if they go bishop c5 white is
immediately winning after bishop f7
king takes on f7
and queen h5
forking the king and the bishop
now in that game
napoleon did not play
bishop f7
so i'm not going to go through that game
actually
but feel free to look it up yourself
i just think it was a very very messy
game and definitely suspicious
but um i was doing so some looking
around and there's a couple ideas black
can have
first off
let's take a look at queen f6 queen f6
holds on to the pawn
uh develops the queen and you can't
really punish this i don't think i think
after castles
and knight e7 after c3 and knight c6 i
think this position is pretty balanced
um white is slightly better
because you take on d4 here
and after queen takes d4 you play
something like queen c2 i think this is
fine for either side
queen f6 is probably a legit move that
you can play
um
but i guess there there's two other
moves we should look at one is c5 trying
to hold on to the pawn with their own
pawn but here white doesn't really need
to do much uh that's special they castle
black plays d5
um trying to
break up this center here but white can
just
take bishop d6
and c3 trying to get them to take and
recapture with the knight to develop
further
if you play rook e1
looks very natural it's actually just me
by knight e7 and black is ready to
castle
um i don't think i i would prefer to
play rookie one and force black to
block i think i would rather have them
need to spend a move to block anyway
because
um i guess the tempo you gain by moving
your rook uh black gains it back by
developing their knight
uh so that's why i'm recommending
c3 now knight e7 and you can take on d4
after they take on d4 queen takes and
after black castles i think white is
just a healthy pawn up i don't see
any crazy way black can try and win this
back right away
i guess there's like queen a5 in the
future but that can be met with knight
c3 i think this is just um
i mean ic3 comes first so i think this
is just a a nice position for white
healthy pawn
the the last idea
this is
this is where i
went down the slippery slope
d5
is again trying to
uh muddy the waters a little bit and i
think white should take with the bishop
white can take with either but i think
taking with the bishop it's a bit nicer
and
okay if black tries to hit the bishop
you just retreat the bishop back to b3
and natural development should get you
far enough in the game
um we have
moves like knight d2 trying to develop
the knights queen f3 it looks like
you're blocking the knight but you're
trying to go knight e4
um getting
the bishop pair
and after a5
white's white has a game you play
sorry not a3 you can play a4 here and be
fine
uh develop the bishop
somewhere i think d2 and then get your
rooks in the center this is pretty
pretty straight forward if they play c6
the real trouble comes when they play
knight f6 because now they're
threatening to take on d5 and win their
pawn back
or maybe
some some ideas of taking on e4 combined
with queen e7 it's a little slow for
that plan but it exists
and here white should be content with
taking the pawn
all right that was easy we just take the
pawn we're good that's it
unfortunately that's not the case
black does want to try and get their
pawn back and d5 is going to be their
target for the next couple of moves
mainly because the bishop can't move
um
if this bishop moves
uh the queen hangs
um
so okay c6 looks very natural uh this is
actually a blunder c6 trying to get the
the bishop fails to bishop f7 and if the
king takes you win the queen
or if king e7
well now you just trade queens and after
f3
white is just in a winning end game
they're up two pawns absolutely no
reason why they should lose this
so okay if c6 doesn't work how are we
going to put pressure on d5
we go bishop to e6 and again you cannot
capture because you would hang your
queen
so knight to c3
just reinforcing d5 reinforcing e4
and now we're met with c6 because now
there's no bishop to f7
and
now white has to decide what to do
uh you have two options here
uh one which
i guess is fine
i'm not a big fan of it is queen a4
just pinning the pawn
but now knight takes d5 and after ed5
bishop d5 and castles
bishop e6
black is the one with the bishop pair
and it is a fairly open board
and the pawns are pretty symmetrical
so i think having the bishop pair is a a
nice
advantage here for black now white does
have the move you can start with like
rook d1
this is fine but again i i hardly think
black has any problems
so rather than queen a4
a bit sharper is bishop to g5
and after bishop to g5 i think both
sides need to start
paying attention and being accurate
black should go bishop to e7
if they take the pawn right away
i think white is doing just fine after
e5 this knight is pinned
and if you try and go bishop e7
then white is going to be winning after
pawn takes bishop takes
you can just trade on f6
and black structure
is not a structure this is just a bunch
of of targets as far as i'm concerned
um
or if they take with the pawn then
bishop to e3 and again
these are just targets it's not a pawn
structure
they're not helping each other out
so
you can't really take on d5
so
bishop to
e7 after bishop to e7
let's see what do i have here in my
notes
we have castles
so castle's long
you're putting more pressure on the d
file
and here
there there's two moves that black has
there's queen a5
and after queen a5 there's two options
that white has
the first option
is to uh bail out with like queen a4
um
not in this position i don't believe
um but you take on f6 first bishop f6
e5
bishop g5 check
f4
and bishop takes f4
queen f4 cd5 uh this is where they have
the option they can bail out with queen
i4 and just get like a equal endgame
or they can play king b1 and keep this
alive keep the queens on the board so
this is one idea
um if they go queen a5
the other idea black has
instead of going queen a5 right away
uh probably more critical
is taking on d5
and
in this position statically
white is down a piece
but we're gonna get it back
the only move here is ed5
uh after e to d5
this is similar to like um one of those
knight d5 sacrifices in the nightdorf
and
black cannot capture on d5 if they
capture with the queen
thank you for the queen
if they capture with the bishop
uh you take on f6 they take on f6
queen a4 check
and this piece is falling
so you will get your minor piece back
and white is up a pawn
and now after some moves by black you
see like g6
white has this idea of h4
and h5
and
just run the pawn all the way down to h6
why don't you after king h8
king b1 just trying to get away from any
possible checks
queen d6 you can trade
and we'll see that we actually get into
a
losing
uh rook and game white is up a pawn this
pawn's on h6 trapping the king
it's gonna be relatively simple to get
these rooks to the seventh rank
so bishop takes d5 won't work
at the same time knight takes d5 won't
work because this will also lead to a
losing rook and the game
after bishop e7
and now if knight e7 this is meant by
queen takes g7
you're attacking the rook you're
attacking the queen you cannot save both
and if rook g8 trying to trade queens
well i'm going to take your queen and
laugh and say check
so queen takes e7 is forced because of
this and now knight takes d5 bishop
takes d5 and now instead of taking right
away you take on g7 hitting the rook
hitting the bishop you're going to be
winning material
rook f8 to save the rook is met with
rook d5
and now
rook e5 is a threat supported by the
queen
so black must play f6 and met by a queen
trade rook to e1 king f7 and rook d7
white is killing black
king g6 and take on b7 is just disaster
so many extra puns
so
what does black do
they can't capture on d5
they're going to go for some counter
play queen to a5
and after queen to a5
i believe a nice continuation for white
is bringing the rook towards the center
this is exactly like our classical night
dwarf in where again
if black decides to try and capture
well we run into some big problems
because of this pin
the uh
the position here just is not good for
black queen takes f6 is possible knight
d5 is possible there's so much so many
ways to win
um
so that being said black shouldn't
capture on d5 with the bishop however in
this position they do have knight takes
d5 which is one of their only moves
actually the only move to continue
and here
white's only move to keep an advantage
is queen g7
this has the exact same ideas we've been
talking about it hits the rook
you're looking to take on d5 and if
bishop takes rook takes e7 should be
winning um so black needs to castle get
the king out of the center defend the
rook on h8
um but now there is rook takes d5 a
couple things going on with this move
um
first knight takes c3 doesn't look too
friendly
second after rook takes d5 you're taking
the defender of e7 uh so it's like
giving up a rook for two pieces
and black captures back if they capture
with the bishop
this is just lost after bishop takes e7
rook takes e7 is not lost
um
if rook takes e7 there is bishop to e6
trapping the rook back here
uh and what is it
i guess you go queen f6
and black starts getting active pieces i
guess
but taking with the bishop does keep up
the pressure because you're hitting the
rook
and after moving the rook to e8 uh queen
to e5 protecting you're gonna be winning
this bishop back
this uh
this should be just winning and it is so
they can't take with the bishop they
have to take with the rook
now you take on e7
and rook to e8 is mandatory you have to
keep up the pressure you have to stay in
time with white's development and
activity so rookie hitting the bishop
making white react is the way to go
um it should also be mentioned you you
definitely cannot play knight d5 because
it hangs checkmate
so don't be greedy don't take the rook
defend your piece move it out of danger
and now rook f5 is an idea hitting the f
pawn you can just play f3
and i was going to end my analysis here
but i asked myself what is you know does
black have any threats here and black
can continue the game with b5 the idea
is going b4 hitting the knight and after
the knight moves coming in with the
queen and the bishop so
white does have to respond to this
um b3 is good
this is playable
it's still
much better for white
but i wanted to give myself the world's
biggest headache so i started analyzing
rook takes e6
and taking with the rook is uh not good
for black because of queen f8 the king
is forced to the seventh rank and now
you take on f7 so white gets another
pawn
and after king d6 bishop e7
white will end up winning an exchange
so
uh they can't really take back with the
rook i was looking uh they have to stay
back with the pawn which looks a little
scary at first because now this queen
does have more influence over the board
in general it keeps black's king stuck
to the back rank
so
uh here there's also this tactic queen
f7
hitting the rook and if the rook simply
moves you have queen to e6 picking up
the other rook this rook is being hit
that's just winning for for white so
black must uh give back an exchange
and white should take the rook with
check
and after just a couple more moves here
blocking with the queen
um i didn't want to trade queens this is
just uh it lends itself to black um but
this should be uh a draw
or at least very balanced um
but queen takes b5 is probably white's
only try left
and after queen d4 by white
i think queen two e8
king b7 queen e7 and you have to move
the king back you can't uh do anything
with the queen you hang your queen
uh queen's also busy defending the rook
so i think here
uh this position has never been reached
but it looked like there were a lot of
only moves and i thought this is very
exciting i would love to see this played
in the game but i i believe
this position
should be a draw
i think black is active enough
but computers are lending themselves
towards white and it looks like um i
mean white oops white does still have a
few ideas with playing eight like a
three
b3
um
but this probably deserves way more
analysis than i can give it for our
lecture here we are 10 minutes over um
but this is it
this is our our first part of many parts
to the scotch game here's our third move
sidelines i hope you guys are excited
about this gambit as i am